Hello I’m Daven Hiskey and today we’ve
got something a little different for you.
We received a question from a TodayIFoundOut
subscriber on whether or not tapping a shaken
soda can actually results in less foam spewing
out, as is the widely held belief.
This seemed interesting enough to us, but
when we looked far and wide for a definitive
answer, we uncharacteristically came up empty.
So we decided to run an experiment ourselves
to find out the answer.
And just before we get into that, you should
know this episode is brought to you by iFixit,
the free online repair manual for everything,
written by everyone!
Before you start your next DIY repair, head
over to iFixit.com/brainfood and check out
iFixit’s high quality parts, tools, and
thousands of free repair guides.
Alright, now, to be clear, when looking at
answering the question of whether tapping
a shaken can of shaken soda actually does
anything, certainly there are many otherwise
reputable sources throwing out an opinion
on both sides of the argument.
But outside of Snopes, nobody seems to have
bothered to experimentally test whether tapping
the can does anything.
And as for Snopes, while they technically
did do an experiment, this was a reported
sample-size of just three runs (although they
do allude to "a variety of experiments" not
reported).
It is possible one doesn't need a large sample
size here to get meaningful results, so perhaps
three runs is a perfectly sufficient sample.
However, Snopes gives no hard quantitative
data (only anecdotal observations) on this
one, and did not necessarily shake each of
the cans the exact same way (though did time
it and presumably the shaking was approximately
the same if they had the same person shaking
each time).
But needless to say, while Snopes' conclusion
may end up being perfectly correct, we weren't
really comfortable stating it as a definitive
answer here given the way the experiment was
conducted and lack of hard data.
But if you're curious, their results indicated
that tapping the side of the can produced
slightly less foam than simply waiting to
open it, but otherwise from a practical standpoint
didn't really make a difference.
As for expert opinions, these also were conflicting,
though perhaps the best such source in Cornell
University biochemist, and one of the world's
leading beverage foam experts (and, yes, that’s
a thing), Karl J. Siebert, rang in on the
side that at best tapping the can does nothing
in his opinion, and even potentially makes
the problem worse.
As Dr. Siebert states, by tapping the can,
"you risk creating more bubbles."
Despite this, many otherwise reputable sources
claim that tapping the can does actually help.
Why?
As you're probably aware, when you shake the
can, the agitation causes some of the dissolved
carbon dioxide in the container to form bubbles
at various nucleation sites on the inner surface.
It's also further widely held that some of
the bubbles formed will stick to the inside
of the container at these various nucleation
sites, rather than rising to the top.
When the can is opened and the high pressure
thus removed, these bubbles rapidly expand
and shoot to the top of the container, pushing
out some of the liquid with them.
Thus, the hypothesis is that by tapping on
the can, you can dislodge these bubbles and
cause them to float to the top before opening
the container, so that when you do open the
can, the gas can expand and escape without
taking any liquid with it.
Seems reasonably enough, but does this actually
work?
To begin with in our little experiment, we
needed a device that could shake our soda
cans exactly the same every single time.
The Shakenator T-3000 we made to do this works
such that with each button press, it shakes
the can exactly 10 times with a stroke length
of 1.125 inches or 2.9 cm.
Through a bit of experimentation, we ultimately
found that at our coldest measured temperatures
about 150 shakes (at about 8.8 complete shakes
per second) was around the point where we
started getting very good, measurable results
with Coke cans, so went with that for the
number of shakes.
Because temperature is a big factor in how
much foam is produced, the device also reports
the temperature after each run, along with
the number of shakes and the time it took
for the run to complete.
Now to the experiment.
There are a variety of ways we could have
done this, but as we're far more interested
in the amount of foam coming out, rather than
the amount of carbon dioxide, we're choosing
to measure the liquid that comes out of a
can, glass bottle, and plastic bottle when
the respective containers are: shaken and
then tapped on the side, shaken and then tapped
on the top, shaken but not tapped- simply
waiting the same time interval as if we tapped
it, and then shaken, and quickly opened upon
removal from the machine.
This latter one is particularly of interest
as one alternate hypothesis often put forth
on why tapping the can does increase your
odds of avoiding a fizzy bath has nothing
to do with the tapping itself, but is because
people tapping the container wait a short
interval before opening it, giving some of
the carbon dioxide time to re-dissolve into
the liquid and any formed bubbles to rise
to the top where they won't push any liquid
out.
Also, just because we were curious, we ran
an additional experiment shaking several cans
and then opening them at intervals to see
how long it would take for no more liquid
to be pushed out.
Obviously the results here will vary for other
shaking scenarios based on a variety of factors,
but we were really just curious at about broad
ballpark numbers here.
So what were our results?
Well, it turns out that the actual tapping
of the can does nothing.
However, we were very surprised to note that
the seemingly insignificant time interval
here of 20 seconds from shaking to open actually
did make a huge difference in the amount of
foam produced.
And, in fact, on the runs when we opened the
can as fast as possible after being shaken,
even just a change of a few seconds appears
to have made a big difference in foam output,
as you'll see from the results which show
that that portion, which was the only one
not precisely timed, is the only place we
really saw a large variance in resulting foam,
even though every open in that case was within
a few seconds of each other.
As for the rest of the subtle variance in
other runs, it was interesting to observe
how even the tiniest change in the opening
speed of the containers, which results in
the pressure being released at different rates,
made a very measurable difference in the foam
produced to the point where I was eventually
able to roughly predict the foam output based
on how I judged my opening speed, despite
the fact that in all cases with the can and
glass bottles, it only took a fraction of
a second to open them completely.
Specifically, using video footage of a dozen
openings on each, we measured an average of
0.07 seconds to fully open the glass bottles
and 0.22 seconds for the cans.
With the plastic bottles, this was likewise
very similarly timed each time, though took
on average about 1.91 seconds to fully twist
the cap off, with the slightly wider variance
there resulting in a bit larger range in output
foam.
As for tapping in the air vs. on a hard surface,
it would seem this did not have a noticeable
effect either way.
And because it actually takes quite a bit
of shaking to get a measurable amount of foam
spillage (using a gram as the smallest increment-
for reference here the containers in question
contained roughly 340 grams of liquid), we're
guessing in real world scenarios where people
are trying to reduce foam by tapping, nobody's
tapping the can vigorously enough to make
a noticeable difference in foam output.
It's also noteworthy that whether tapping
30 times or 50 made no real difference here
in terms of the expected outcome.
Another interesting point is that the plastic
bottles produced significantly more foam,
despite it taking much longer to fully open
them.
As previously mentioned, based on our observations
with all container types, even a fraction
of a second change in opening speed made a
noticeable difference in foam output.
And given it took roughly 13 times longer
to open the plastic containers fully compared
to the average of the glass and cans, one
might have initially expected the plastic
containers would produce much less foam as
a result, not more.
Given how much carbon dioxide is added significantly
affects the taste of the beverage, we're presuming
Coca-Cola does not vary the initial carbonation
level added based on container type.
If that's correct, we're guessing that the
plastic containers must contain a much greater
number of nucleation sites than glass or aluminum,
ultimately producing many more bubbles for
the same shakes.
This brings us to how long we had to wait
until no foam was produced.
We initially expected we'd have to go out
to intervals of maybe even as much as an hour
to see the foam completely disappear, but
we were woefully incorrect on this point.
In fact, our first experimental run of just
60 seconds of waiting ended up producing no
foam whatsoever despite the 150 vigorous shakes
and the small geyser produced at a few second
interval given those shakes.
We then broke it down to 10 second intervals
and found at the colder temperature it took
just 50 seconds for foaming out of the container
to no longer occur and at 40 seconds, while
there was a slight overflow onto the lid area,
it was not even a gram's worth and certainly
didn't naturally spill off the container.
At the higher room temperature, the results
were surprisingly similar at 40 seconds producing
just slightly more foam than at the 40 second
mark in the colder temperature, measuring
in at 1 gram, 0 grams, and 3 grams in our
three runs.
Similarly, the 50 and 60 second marks at room
temperature mimicked the 40 and 50 second
marks respectively at the near refrigeration
temperature.
As to why there is so little foam being produced
after such a short interval, it would seem
to us there are two possibilities, both of
which may be coming into play.
The first possibility is that the carbon dioxide
is rapidly being redissolved in the liquid.
But as we didn't measure the actual escaped
C02 compared to an unshaken container, we
can't say for certain to what extent that
is happening.
The second possibility is simply that all
the bubbles created from the shaking rise
to the top in this time span and, with no
further shaking causing more bubbles to form
at the nucleation sites, the undissolved carbon
dioxide is simply escaping when you open the
can without pushing out any liquid.
Supporting the idea that this is the bigger
factor in this case is footage of the shaken
glass and plastic bottles which show a dramatic
drop-off in created bobbles in a relatively
short time span after shaking is stopped,
with those created all rising to the top relatively
quickly and no visible bubbles clinging to
the sides as is often stated happens when
people talk about the benefits of tapping
the container.
Further, while we didn't measure the carbon
dioxide output, for what it's worth, observationally
even when no significant foam was produced,
there still sounded like a lot more gas escaping
when opening these shaken cans compared to
opening cans that had just been sitting around,
which we did several times just to compare
the sound back to back.
Though, of course, further experimentation
measuring the actual carbon dioxide output
would need to be done to know for sure.
So there you have it.
We now know for certain that tapping a can
of soda does absolutely nothing to reduce
foam and it is actually the short time interval
taken to tap the can that is reducing foaming
vs. simply opening the can immediately.
It also very much appears that tapping the
container vigorously, which while potentially
could have produced more foam via further
agitation, did not produce any practical increase
in fizz.
And while your results will vary based on
things like temperature, atmospheric pressure,
and how much a given can was shaken, it would
very much appear in all cases you really don't
need to wait more than around a minute or
so for things to stabilize to the point where
you can safely open the soda container without
risk of a foam over, even if you open the
container quickly.
Speaking of doing experiments, the next time
you’re looking to figure out how to open
your phone for a DIY repair, you won’t have
to experiment if you head on over to ifixit,
the free online repair manual for everything,
written by everyone, where it will tell you
exactly how to take that device apart in a
clear, step by step guide.
iFixit has over 25,000 such free repair guides
and videos showing you how to fix or take
apart and put back together all sorts of gadgets
from iPhones and Samsung Galaxy devices, to
Xbox’s, Pcs and more.
Helpful in the process of tearing down devices
and putting them back together, or just building
can-shaking machines, is their Pro-Tech Tool
Kit designed for electronics repair, including
an electrostatic discharge safety strap and
tweezers, a swivel-top magnetic precision
driver with 64 bits that are magnetically
held in place in the case, and a wide variety
of plastic opening tools, spudgers, and picks
to safely pry with, along with a suction cup
to pull screens up.
But by far, in my opinion, the best and most
unique feature of this Pro-Tech Tool Kit are
those magnetically held 64 bits.
In most other such kits, bits are usually
held in place via hard plastic, which is a
major pain when things are inevitably too
tight and otherwise over time loosen so the
bits fall out.
With this kit, the bits are super easy to
take out and put in, and once in, stay their
very securely.
The whole thing conveniently rolls up for
easy storage has a lifetime warranty, and
is only $59.99.
So if you want to tackle your next DIY project
or repair with the Pro Tech Toolkit, or perhaps
want to purchase it as a Christmas present
for someone, please visit ifixit.com/brainfood
to snag the fully-loaded Pro Tech Toolkit
for only $59.99.
And thank you to iFixit for supporting this
channel.
Bonus Fact:
• Just for fun, we also ran this experiment
on cans of Dr. Pepper to see if the results
changed at all.
They did not in terms of the main points already
made.
However, what was interesting to note was
that the Dr. Pepper produced about half as
much foam on average as the Coca-Cola for
each of the scenarios.
There are a variety of potential ingredients
that can cause a difference here.
For instance, with many diet sodas that contain
aspartame, they end up producing more foam
because aspartame lowers the surface tension
of the liquid much more than sugar or corn
syrup will.
It's possible Coca-Cola simply contains more
surfactants than Dr. Pepper.
Or it's possible Dr. Pepper just contains
much less carbon dioxide than Coca-Cola; given
the amount of carbon dioxide dissolved in
the beverage greatly influences the taste
and mouth feel, we're presuming there is a
reasonable variance from flavor to flavor.
And, anecdotally, it does always seem like
Dr. Pepper goes flat much faster than a lot
of soft drinks....
But that's an experiment for another day.
For now, whatever is the underlying cause,
we thought it was interesting to note how
much less foam an equally shaken can of Dr.
Pepper produces compared to a can of Coke.
So thanks for watching this video, I know
this was a little different than our normal
stuff, but I hope you enjoyed it anyway.
And if you did, please do give it a like below
and share it with anyone you think might find
it interesting.
We’d also like to again thank ifixit for
sponsoring this one as well as our patrons
on patreon.
As you might imagine, rather than the normal
24 or so hours most of our videos take to
produce, give or take a few hours on average,
this one took a lot longer, ringing in at
just over 100 hours; so given the expected
YouTube ad revenue on a video like this is
woefully small given our average expected
views, without the support of ifixit and our
patrons, we really wouldn’t have been able
to spend the time and money to research the
answer on a question like this where the answer
isn’t definitively known somewhere.
So thanks again to ifixit and you patrons,
and thank you for watching.